the jurogan experience
this uh area in the sunder bands these
guys have to they have to do a survey of
how many tigers there are just so they
can keep track and they go with rifles
and they have these helmets on and the
helmets have a face yeah
wow
you got to do that or he would jump on
you
well they think i'm running and [ __ ] am
i playing and if i if they accidentally
because they they chew on my arm and
stuff and if they accidentally bite my
head they can hurt me but actually i
don't mean it right right right and when
they on my shoulder i let them bite me
in my legs and you're just playing yeah
but they could pierce my skull jesus
how big did they get 600 500.
that's when they're eating good man
that's when they're eating good
but you never felt nervous around them
or
you never felt like they might kill one
of your friends accidentally definitely
one of my friends and family
you know this the relationship with
tigers and stuff are different than with
lions and stuff lions are like dogs and
stuff they like hanging out with family
but tiger only hangs out with you oh
really yeah only with you and you hope
you better hope he doesn't like one of
your children because then you can't
play with your children he might kill
you oh my god that's crazy that's what
the tiger the crate they get they get
attached to one person oh they're not
getting they're not no family people
one person
whoa they don't [ __ ] around with a whole
bunch of people they're not like my life
hanging out there on the front table
your table hanging out with the family
and stuff really yeah tigers don't do
that that's you notice in the in the
wild they don't even anything i see them
they're gonna kill yeah they don't even
want to be seen the only time they're
with a female when it's mating season
that's the mating season if they see you
they're going to kill you
i wonder why they have that coloration
the
beautiful pattern on their body i wonder
if that's just because it's so
when you see a tiger that looks that's
stunning like all the i bet it makes you
freeze more because they're so stunning
like they look so they look beautiful
when there was over a gentleman's house
they had a tiger we were talking about
and i saw this cat it's called a tabby
they're different than the stripe they
have like patches of orange they're not
stripes they're patches on like cream
color and i was going to hug the cat he
said mike
don't cut the cat just go go down low
because i feel so pretty oh my god he
said no mike don't touch it and i forget
it wasn't my cat if it's not your cat
don't touch the cat yeah if it's not
your cat don't touch it some cats will
[ __ ] you up oh yeah without knowing they
hit you they're punchy just like wow
knock you cold yeah
knock you cold
but having a big cat for a pet
i just swim in the pool with them
really and they love swimming so what
did you do when you weren't around like
if you had to leave you got to go to
camp if you had to do anything like what
did you do with the cats they came with
me really they're traveling with you i
had 18 wheels they have big trucks wow
they had big they live big baby i'm the
heavyweight champ of the world they live
big when i go somewhere they go with me
wow even if it takes days in the thing
i'll put i would
i would have them um
expedited on the plane
i didn't care so when you got to a place
like say if you were training like for a
fight and you brought them with you what
would you do have a cage set up for them
i would have the trucks i would always
have the in
encasement already built at the house
but first day morning i would have my um
my receipt for my you know you have to
have every time they move you have to
have a license for them if they move
into vegas all right we have to have the
vegas like they move new york we need a
new york license right right right and
new york is so hard to get a life for
live animals you know endangered species
so hard there was a dude they found uh
alligators alligator no no that's not
what happened
this is what they had in new york right
yes in new york
he had an alligator in the bathtub right
and he had a tiger yeah and they started
oh this
this stupid no you have to listen to
that yes please he thought he was
somebody's father's parent the tiger in
the lion saw the fight the titan or the
the tiger and the alligator started
fighting and he tried to break it up can
you imagine you know
of course you know what apartment since
you brought it up of course you know
listen how do you do that in new york
city crazy this the tigers 400 pounds
man
and not a little tiger remember the guy
in the subway had a 500 pound tiger yeah
he was the guy that lived in in new york
in the subway he had a 500 pound tiger
that is so crazy look at the size of
this look at this stuff look at the
police look i tell you right here this
is in this house man that is so crazy
no no no look how big that thing is man
joe joe look how big that is no joe my
cat was a joke he was living with these
kids look that's my cat's that big but
joe look we're living with these cats
and they're not trained oh my god my cat
is true my cat lives with me sleeps in
my bed you know this cat this cat's not
this is a wild cat man oh my god look at
that
wow you can't hang out with this cat man
they're so beautiful though like look at
his face that's the thing look at that
face of that cat in the window with the
that's the 42 fake out man
he's hanging by the way he's full like
floating in the air he's looking at this
guy he's dropping down from the ceiling
i know he's like ain't this some
[ __ ] look at that cat's face though
look how pretty they are
oh no that's that's the that's the fake
out man they're pretty that's how they
get you to [ __ ] stand still i think
that's what i'm saying i think they're
so beautiful i think that might be it
because they're they're colorations in
the i mean they're it's not sneaky no
but this is the thing right this is the
thing i never understood about tigers
right
they got someone they don't want you to
look at them no cats don't want you to
look at them
like that yeah the
dogs have a problem with that too
sometimes they'll make that face-to-face
stuff well they think you're challenging
them that's what it is yeah they don't
understand that's what i think
they don't know that they when they love
each other it's like sideways action
they you know they love on each other
but they don't like stare either eye to
eye is like i don't know what you're
thinking you might be challenging
some dogs will do that if you eyeball
them that's why they're suitable i never
knew that since you said looking in the
face they think you're challenging them
for dominance like my golden retriever
you met mike um marshall
yeah
we have pictures you cuddle and we don't
um but those are like the sweetest dogs
they don't challenge you ever so he
never like really like he collects me in
the eyes just because we've known each
other for so long he knows it's not like
a challenging thing that it's we're just
being sweet to each other but dog even a
dog like that doesn't like looking in
the eye they're like looking around your
eyes you look at your face you know
what's interesting about big cats
especially
if a tiger if you go like that's my
tigers and then caveman if i go and i
see him he's happy to see me run to the
gate i go in i play with them i bring
them out with me but if i go there in
there like this
look at you hear them eye to eye they're
looking at you when they're looking at
you like this
is looking at it no no that's not a good
day oh no don't go in there that day
when they just looking at you
it's crazy that people love to have uh
pets like that they love it
like to live in an apartment and kill a
tiger like that
um
how much do i defeat it
listen
and where's all the [ __ ] they don't eat
much but they eat all day
oh
they eat a little all day
well they're so big
they so you must be just giving it raw
meat right yeah chicken
yeah a lot of chicken i like giving them
chicken and i give them horse meat like
you give them a whole chicken right i'm
gonna get two or three of them but then
i give them the horse meat this is when
it gets fun when you get the whole
side of a cow or something
like this whole ribbon you
just throw it in there and they slam and
boom and hit it against the fence and
hit the air and grab and then run inside
like a joke